first the restorer dust off some of the
surface dirt
he uses a soft brush and gentle
movements to avoid further destruction
then he prepares a cleaning solution he
applies the cleanser to the Madonna's
face and body he makes sure the statue
doesn't absorb too much water because
that would cause more deterioration next
the restorer wipes the statue down with
a damp C sponge for serious stains he
combines alcohol and ammonia
he applies the cleansing mixture using a
cotton swab
he lightly scrubs off the deep stains
the alcohol evaporates quickly so it's
not on the surface of the statue long
enough to do any more damage
the restorer uses rabbit glue for the
next step it's a strong and flexible
adhesive that won't chip or crack he
dissolves some glue in distilled water
he applies to the cloth exposed
underneath the broken plaster
then he mixes a special plaster called
gesso with a rabbit glue he dabs the
plaster mixture onto the glued sections
to fill in the gaps in Madonna's robes
after the first coat of plaster on the
roads dries then he sculpts the robes
contours using a surgical scalpel he
blends the repair into the original
plaster and sands it until it looks
seamless
he mixes water-based paint to match the
original colors then he carefully covers
the repaired sections blending the old
with the new he seals the paint with
carnauba wax it gives the surface of the
statue a hard and resilient finish
it can take up to four months to restore
a damaged statue a sculpture that's
hundreds of years old can look as good
as new in just a few months then
churchgoers can enjoy it for centuries
to come
you